hello and welcome to the lobby games
spots weekly hang every Tuesday at 2
p.m. Pacific right here on Gamespot
that's right that is my name look at
that it's my name and I'm joined by
three handsome young gentlemen Jeff Gman
hello Hi how are you I'm spry you're
spry yeah I'm a young gentleman I'm like
ready to go Peter Brown slightly yes
less young now happy birthday thank you
30 years old how's it feel I feel like
an adult yep finally no I don't that's
why youve been playing outrun 3D on your
big fat DS did you want me to pull it
out yes I do cuz otherwise I look like
an [__] or just looks like you're
looking at his crotch true what did you
do to that thing yeah there's like a
third party battery you can add on to it
gives it like four times about five
times the battery life and it weighs
about 20 pounds now yeah I feel it [__]
that come on no one wants this my dainty
gamer wrists can't handle it I haven't
taken it off so nice work must must be
must be worth something Chris Waters hey
Danny how you doing buddy oh good I
watched you hosting this show at about
11:00 in Poland last week that's the
appropriate hour that they should air
this I always felt this show had more of
a nighttime vibe to it you know loue
room kind of thing it was like back in
the day when I used to watch on the spot
at like midnight and Ireland it was
always the secret with all these live
shows is like it was always timed like
oh this way people over there could
watch it but the secret was like and
they'll probably be like completely
wasted yeah yeah probably something like
that makes those chat rooms real funky
uh yeah that was fun I was over there
playing The Witcher 3 oh go on should I
talk about can I talk about The Witcher
3 I don't know if I'm supposed to talk
about but no there's no Bargo on it
we're just working on a bunch of
features uh me and Andy are going to put
out on I think it's like mid time next
month that game's really good there's a
lot of hype for that game are are you
feeling the hype I am now I played with
you too I wasn't like I was kind of
didn't you guys play any with you to
yeah it found it kind of difficult to
get up to speed on it just the controls
and stuff it had that wheel kind of like
I don't know Eastern European video game
thing of like like games like stalker
where you weren't really sure why you
doing for the longest time um the
prologue and all this does a real good
job of teaching you but then when you
get launched out into the world it kind
of stops being it felt like it wasn't a
Witcher anymore and it felt like it was
like fantasy Red Dead Redemption which
seems which was yeah I was I was
watching some of this footage uh at your
desk
yesterday I'm super impressed with that
looks I haven't I haven't gone to see it
it's they've been showing it at E3 for
the past couple of years and it's it's
last couple years it's been our final
appointment of the show oh really uh so
everyone but me goes like I'm you know
CU they're they're packing people in CU
it's the last demo of the show and I
never want to like it's already a
crowded room I don't want to be like one
more guy in there but like Vinnie and
Brad and all those guys like they cram
into this thing and and catch the
Witcher 3 demo and each time last two
years they come back on like yeah that
thing looks legit thing looks serious so
this is like kind of my first time
seeing it like yeah looks real good H
those videos should be out in a couple
of weeks we and Andy got to play about
six hours each um and it wasn't it was
like the little prolog area but then it
was just like go and do whatever you
want and we did and that self up on
Gamespot in the next couple of weeks uh
stuff that's coming has been up on Giant
Bomb you guys just spent two hours
enjoying PlayStation home yeah I just
walked off of uh our set where we've
been streaming the final day of
PlayStation home I think that stream
might still be up okay it might just
hopefully it's just a picture of the you
go to joh bomb.com chat right now right
now no turn this thing off uh you can
catch uh I believe it should be a shot
of the uh the Wipeout DJ dance floor or
the the DJ booth full of people there
was a guy dressed up like a Dr Pepper 10
machine okay what PlayStation Home
apparently got weird 10 specifically 10
is it just like all these brands that
were like a little late to the to the
party not that there was ever on time
think about when they were creating
zones for PlayStation home and what
products were around like to give you
some context I was in the Wipeout Museum
there's The Godfather 2 Zone it's like
stuff like that the the Konami a the
Konami Penthouse has uh ads for um like
uh Pro Evo 2011 and torn down all the
kajima Productions signs yeah it's all I
mean you know just like actual Konami
there are no video games in that zone so
it's it's pretty much it's a fitness
center yeah exactly it's like a
geological strata of a specific time in
gaming it's kind it was interesting I
had a better time doing it than I
thought I would uh but that thing I
think is going to be up for most of the
rest of the day and night so like it's
that last chance to get those
PlayStation Home trophies it's done
tonight yeah they're shutting it down
they shut down the Japanese servers a
while ago and announced this is the date
for us I believe is how it went end of
the fiscal year yeah weirdly timed maybe
not that weirdly but uh yeah I don't
know I that was the the weird thing
about PlayStation home is that uh you
would always mock it and then you would
mock it to the people that worked on it
and they would kind of
go yeah but it brings in a lot of money
actually like between the marketing
opportunities and you know ads and
posters and and the actual sale virtual
Goods they showed like early movie
trailers and stuff uh all that marketing
stuff apparently added up to a decent
chunk of change for them not enough to
Port it forward to PS4 I guess but like
it seemed like that thing served some
purpose for someone even if it never
technically left beta I remember I I
chatted to some folks years ago um uh
for for a video feature and it just came
up that they all met through PlayStation
Home and one of the weirdest things I
found in it was that they said that like
the amount of like skey like pedophilic
stuff that was going on there that
wasn't monitored by Sony or anything was
like pretty like all over the place I
mean there a language filter but it
still has voice chat it still has you
know text chat you know it's still going
to be a little skevy around the edges
you know it's it can't be second life
where it's just like full-on crazy but
you know maybe that's where they went
wrong yeah exactly if they really leaned
into it and just never go full second
life
am all right well we've talked a lot
about PlayStation Home far more than I
was expecting on today's show what if
the most concurrent viewers that users
that thing ever had was today oh yeah
people just like right back it see it
die and you can go download it right now
you have to search in the store but you
you can dig it out and download it and
get in there and your Sony are like oh
my god look they came eventually they
came keep it
on no probably not no probably not uh
Jeff gersman I'm Peter Brown we usually
do a a section called ask the reviewer
where we kind of get your ideas about
the games you've reviewed both of you
reviewed Axion Verge for your respective
Publications um that is correct Peter
Brown you enjoyed this game quite a lot
I love this game yeah would you like to
know why I would like to know why you
enjoy this video game oh okay uh well so
many of the games that it that it sort
of uh takes a lot of inspiration from
like Metroid Super Metroid um even
Bionic Commando two degree mhm um it
sort of takes a lot of elements from
those games
does those like replicates what those
games do so well in a very good way and
then just adds all this crazy stuff on
top of it there like way more weapons
than you need the world is super
interesting and the story just gets
weirder and more complex as it goes and
you find that like everything is
building up and while you're playing you
just enjoy it more and more and then you
get to the end and you're like damn it I
just want to keep playing this game and
you realize that there is reason to keep
playing this game and you know I'm I'm
playing it again a second time right now
just to keep keep going yeah I'm not
sure if I'm going to start another
playthrough or finish up the one I've
got because I have like 98% map and like
82% items or something like that so it's
like I might just wait until now the
game's out there people will probably
just uncover the last little bits over
the next like few days here and then I
can go in and do some stuff uh there
some some some stuff that I haven't done
that you guys it seemed like you and
Lark had found uh there's some crazy
some crazy stuff in this game L Anderson
as well has been speed rning the crop B
at this game I think he he's been
surgically just like dissecting this
thing bit by bit I mean he knows
everything but yeah the speedrun right
now is like 1 hour 45 minutes oh he's
gotten it even lower it was like two
hours yesterday he said now yesterday
was 145 and then he's even like oh I can
shave off about 20 minutes and the
Creator Tom hap who's been working on
this game for five years told him that
he couldn't beat it in less than three
oh really yeah that's just cuz he loves
all the content he made in his game like
he wants to see
cont he doesn't he work for a different
we had him on the show actually pet pet
it's like a side project yeah I think
he's like he was part-time at Petroglyph
while this was in development I'm not
sure if he's still there but yeah that
that that's my understanding yeah uh
yeah it is a really fascinating game
like the It sets itself up like you I
mean obviously you take a look at it
you're like oh like someone wanted to
make a new Metroid game whatever yeah is
it just like it always seemed to me like
a like a real homage kind of thing but
is more to it than that I think it
really benefits from that initial
impression even though that I think will
turn some people off uh that are kind of
sick of like the Retro style at this
point
um it sets itself up and you think like
oh it's going to be Metroid and you
start expecting certain types of
powerups and certain types of weapons
and certain type of game float you see
areas where it's like oh well if I could
roll up into a ball I'd be able to fit
in there and it totally subverts all of
those those expectations and the items
you actually get to do your traversal
and and and kind of make your way
through the world are different and
really exciting um and that for me was
was one of the the coolest surprises
that it just wasn't like some Like Love
Letter to Metro through and through like
I I I personally feel like it is in a
way and I guess but just it everything
has a another layer on top of it that's
original yeah so I mean like for
instance like you know right when you
start you run to the left the gun you
run to get the gun like there are some
things that are like you know like just
carbon copies um I feel like that is I
think they you know like that's used
really well to tr of set up the ways
that it's not Metroid like this address
disruptor this crazy glitch gun that
you're just like yeah like this is the
most interesting tool in the game in my
opinion this lets you transform every
enemy in the game and every enemy
responds to it differently um for
example like this enemy turns into a
little platform that you can ride
another one uh an enemy turns into like
this like you know uh like cement
chomping little thing and it like starts
eating away through the environment in
ways that you couldn't um so you're
really incentivized to use this thing on
on every enemy and also works on the
environment as well there's a lot of
stuff that you can uh transform with
that gun yeah it just quickly becomes
the sort of thing that you just want to
use everywhere like every time you get
to an area where you're like I don't
know what to do next like you know there
are tools that you can use to try to
uncover secrets and in every little nook
and cranny and and I found that just
really rewarding yeah absolutely I
probably 19 hours somewhere around that
was my clock when I finished it but I
think I might have left it running for a
few hours idling it with stuff like this
beam uh you know that that works on
enemies and it works on sort of glitchy
areas that are pretty visible but you
guys they're also you talked about all
this stuff to discover and all these
secrets and you know the sort of
completion percentages how like at the
far end of the spectrum the hidden stuff
the stuff that you find gratifying that
like rewards really close inspection how
esoteric how inaccessible is that stuff
I mean is like fullon Fez deep like get
on some get your pen and paper out like
that kind of stuff there's a little bit
of that in here a little bit of that
Lark did some um manual translation of a
document in an alien language using then
he used a codex to get the English
version of that and then he translated
that language and then other places in
the world where you can't just apply a
filter he was able to devise what it
said like in a glyph like in a wall and
then you there's a password screen in
your menu so you can put in passwords so
by deciphering the language he was able
to translate something in the
environment put in a password which then
allowed him to access an item so unless
he unless you sort of use that sort of
abstract thought like I can apply this
to that and I'll get something out of it
you might only see so much of the game I
mean it's still there's still a lot
there and a lot a lot of stuff that's
easy to find that you're going to feel
feel gratified but if you really want to
dig deep you can and gets even more
interesting yeah yeah there's there's
crazy stuff the the further down you go
but yeah I think it's still enjoyable
like at its base level you know it's a
it's a good solid level of difficulty
it's about right it feels you know it's
like you die here and there yeah um but
but the the death penalty is very slight
and you know you can kind of keep going
and as somebody maybe who hasn't played
many Metroid games like I didn't grow up
playing that era of I was on Commodore
stuff like can you enjoy this without
needing all those like references and
nods and whatnot I think so yeah I think
you know like it it'll I think it'll hit
the hardest for people that have played
those games like I I don't have any real
reverence for Metroid uh they're fine
they're they're fine games but but I'm
not like crazy um but some of the things
that people love about those games right
is like the discovery of new tools and
items that allows you to go to new
places that before you saw and you were
like man I wonder what's there and then
you get something you're like I'm going
to go back I'm going to go do this thing
that I wanted to do like two hours ago
it's the stuff that made Shadow complex
really great it's the stuff that that
made like Symphony of the Night so
outstanding like this this has that same
stuff uh that little guy the guy that
just blew up there if you hack that
thing it starts spitting out Health
instead of bugs it's you know there's
there's just a lot of really cool little
things in here excellent um and this is
all like really early footage from the
game we didn't want to spoil too much of
the the stuff that you find except you
like just a minute ago said the craziest
thing that I've seen in the whole game I
was like watch YouTu going I didn't say
it was
consistent all right well that's let's
draw the spoilers to a close there uh
thanks very much for coming on Jeff
review up on Giant Bomb you guys gave it
five stars yeah five out of five there
quick look up as well that starts with
the beginning of the game and then at
some point I kind of give the warning
and go all right we're going to load up
a save that's cleared it to show like
the traversal stuff that's in there and
all the different tools so if people are
kind of on the fence and just want to
get spoiled that you can you can see
that stuff if you want to perfect and
your review went up this morning as well
or uh no it went live on Monday okay
cool yeah gave it an eight out of 10 uh
I I love the game I there are a couple
areas I felt like were lacking in
attention uh the writing a little bit
for the main character he has very
unrealistic reactions to his predicament
okay and uh yeah you know I mean I think
it's his hair that kind of rubbed me the
wrong way little stuff not a fan uh but
anyway yeah no I love the game I mean
don't worry about the score it's a it's
a game you have to play excellent it's
available on PC PlayStation 4 3 and just
PS4 is it right now and then it'll come
to Vita relatively quickly he's working
on it right now the PC version is coming
out before VA excellent all right so in
the coming and weeks brilli thanks very
much coming on dudes y uh we'll be back
in a second with some uh Mortal Kombat X
nonsense right now they are still making
content content they're not making
that's not a [__] word making content
for evolve the video game uh I actually
heard you guys talking on the Bombcast
about this the like concurrent players
on Steam right now is like a couple
thousand or something yeah yeah it's uh
you know Esports like it's totally a
viable huge platform yeah everyone loves
evolve I love evolve so you and Mary and
a bunch of people here like evolve are
you still playing though cuz like yeah
yeah I played this weekend I played
today uh the new DLC characters are
pretty interesting they sort of
encourage different styles of play that
uh the other ones don't I turned on a
PS4 and noticed it started downloading a
big evolve patch my reaction was to
uninstall evolve that's the how I solved
that problem all right well if you don't
want to uninstall evolve here is a
trailer for some more evolved
content
die Stone
Beast Mark your
target you got so much help and I need
it
all you want some of
this
just
Mortal Kombat XS do it Xs X going to
give it to you X going to give it to you
exhibits fighting game is finally coming
yeah was exhibit in De Jam he wasn't in
De Jam was he I so I don't think so they
brought in some like tertiary people for
de Jam icon maybe he was in there maybe
I don't remember that they're trying to
squash the beef yeah exactly
exactly well if you don't want to play
De John mikon which honestly you should
probably go [__] put De John mikon H
Mortal Kombat X is out pretty soon uh
mid next uh mid next month so like two
weeks away from April 11 yeah we see
same week as GTA 5 on PC video games
Eric Tay's here what up Peter br's here
still here Chris W's here also here Y
and we're going to talk about we're
going to talk about Mortal Kombat 10 cuz
you played it last week Mortal Kombat X
X sorry not 10 even though the last one
was nine 10 2011 Mor Kombat
2011 yeah I was talking about I played
some last week yeah want to know I want
to know I've got a list of all all the
characters that are announced and I want
to basically just get real pissy about
why Barack is not on it yet but first of
all sh first of all you tell tell me
what you think about Mortal Kombat X so
I'm like a street fighter player first
and foremost um I used to play Mortal
Kombat back in the day and I've i'
sampled the the latest ones over the
past few years Mortal Kombat X
definitely has a much better flow to it
uh I would characterize past games as
being very stiff this still has a bit of
that but it's it's much easier to sort
of uh create a combo of your own and
kind of feel like you're you've got
momentum you know and you're not just a
punch and then back to your stance and
then a kick how you finding that is it
three did they call them stance
the three different variations yeah how
is that stuff working uh well so
essentially each character's variation
comes with different moves that are
available to them sometimes that means
that they have access to a weapon
that'll open up some moves um and and I
think that generally there's sort of a
paradigm that's that's goes across all
characters like one maybe have a little
bit more speed one may hit a little bit
harder but it's not like a blanket like
this is the fast version versus the
strong version versus the whatever right
and all the fatalities are across all
three of those variations and what not
yeah there are no special fatalities how
are you enjoying the fatalities they're
they're pretty gruesome man um I don't
know that I enjoy all of them like it's
it's definitely shocking to see some of
this stuff and I think that's where you
get the enjoyment is because the
surprise of like wellow they really
thought about how to tear this
character's body apart um they got real
creative with some look at how like how
all right what percentage of her scalp
are we going to get there should we get
the ears no we're going to go above the
ears this like just makes your skin
crawl cuz it's so slow you can like feel
it happening to you as you do it as you
watch it but um yeah I could do without
them
honestly I think they're I think I mean
oh No Gold Dust they are that's D'Or by
the
way they are a bit over the top that's
actually kind of a throwback one right
there um Ian I'm not saying that that
it's too much I'm just saying that I
don't I don't need them to enjoy this
game like a good fighting game to me is
not about a protracted cut scene where I
dismember a person yeah but it's a big
Mortal Kombat thing right it's been for
a long time one that is genius that one
really you just go on YouTube and and
watch didn't we watch like a super cut
two weeks ago of all oh my god look
[__] eyeballs yeah you had like a
three- hour one going or something yeah
of like every Mortal kombo fatality ever
these are these are pretty great that
Conan skit where he was playing with Rob
gronowski and marshan Lynch before the
Super Bowl and Marshon Lynch is like the
toughest dude in the NFL like beast mode
running back just one of them happens
and he's like oh no stood up he's like
I'm done I got to get out of here int
how are the brutalities uh cuz they they
work so they're different now something
that's more brutal than that they're not
like the old ones where like the old
ones is like okay you're going to do a
crazy long combo and then they're going
to explode into giblets right now it's
kind of like there are like multiple
brutalities it's not just one there are
like limiting factors or like things you
have to do to make them happen like in
the combat in the process of around you
have to fulfill certain criteria and I
believe it's different for every
character and then only then once you've
done that are you allowed to execute the
brutality would it be like get two
uppercuts or like I think it's more more
difficult than that piece might be like
one part of it oh really you know what I
mean so you have to go out of your way
to it's going to be interesting to see
because I like it's one of those things
that they they've said themselves they
want it to be like arcade again where
they want people to figure it out and
then people kind of like word them M
like hey that's how you do the brutality
like I think likew right like he has
like a suer thing where he does a bunch
of portals um and I don't know exactly
how they did it on the stream but it was
like they they met a criteria with him
doing enough portals and the last portal
that he did to end the round like
teleported the guy into a portal and
then he's standing there like with his
arms crossed and then all the giblets
just rain on him and that's a brutality
right there that's a brutality right
there too
nasty uh right yeah that's pretty
she laid a little bug inside of it this
almost like the fatality is almost like
better like these are just kind of okay
that's pretty rough you know what's
interesting is the the X-ray moves that
you pull off in the middle of a fight
when you once your met your meter fills
up by getting hit those are like more
gruesome in a way than a lot of the
fatalities because it's like okay your
vertebrae is just you know your back is
snapped in half and oh your jaw has been
disconnected and now your your skull has
been imploded but you just get right up
but you just get right up and you're
fine no thing nether round's been
streaming bunch of this right yeah like
do like every one like once a week maybe
once every two weeks something like that
yeah they've been showing off characters
and what not and dripping at characters
well let's get to the characters let's
go through every single character that's
been announced for Mortal Kombat X and I
want to hear your guys opinion on it
first of all favorite character Chris
Waters scorpion
nice I play Mortal Combat Mortal Kombat
was banned in my household I was always
terrible at it I never got good at it so
it's just like I'll watch it but my
parents never brought us games but for
some reason like Mom was out of town one
weekend and dad brought us down toown
and he was like what's that game you
guys are talking about we're like oh
World Kombat 2 for like the Amiga and he
was like right let's buy it don't tell
your mom [__] except when you got
fatalities in that game you had to like
swap discs to see them because it was on
like three days was terrible Peter
favorite Mortal Kombat hero uh Ryden
okay wait Raiden or Ryden from met gal
oh howon how do I pronounce a word
that's spelled the same as the other one
uh okay not going to win this
one um either smoke or cabal probably
but neither are uh you know about youny
any good whoa Subzero so
boring for Scorpion
Baraka that [__] all right confirmed
characters uh Cassie cage she's new
she's the daughter of Johnny and Sonia
all right fair enough
d'vorah bug thing right okay that was
anoun a while ago that bug thing they're
all they're all weird things irac the
like green thing yeah he's new no he's
not I mean he's not new he's an orange
ninja so it didn't look as like thing
before he's Naro uh who's Aaron black
he's like a fictional character that
they have in their comic and he's the
cowboy the Gunslinger he's pretty cool
he kind of reminds me of um Deathstroke
though he looks real cool like I would
imagine that that is the Gunslinger from
The Dark Tower Stephen King's Dark Tower
book series like looks I just kind of
when I saw Aaron black I was like
that's when there's just like regular
dude names in the middle of this roster
of like bug Lady Scorpion Subzero Johnny
Stevenson e r o n though I you ever seen
r o n all weird it up a little you say
that but then there's also like Predator
yeah DC predators in this gamec predator
and Jason VES right okay yeah God that's
weird Farah T which is that the big guy
and the small girl with the little girl
on top Fred Krueger claw kind yeah she's
kind of like a mini Baraka no give me
that at least all about that Baraka H
Goro's in it is Goro like a pre-order
bonus yeah pre-order and DLC I think I
think I don't know I know for sure
pre-order okay could be wrong we'll see
uh when is a pre-order Bon I've never
knocked you at DLC H Jackie is a new one
I don't know who Jackie is it's Jack's
daughter Jack's is it actually Jack's
daughter yes does she also have metal
arm Jacqueline Briggs she does not have
metal arm she has kind of
she go gotcha Susan is in
there it's spelled differently it's j a
c Qi she's got like you're right but no
surname you're right no surname yeah
just Jackie yeah we already got one
Jackie Melanie you know Jackie from two
ends in her name all right I'll stop she
doesn't have metal arm she has like AR
like attachments like like kind of like
robotic like daughter like like father
like daughter gotcha uh Johnny Cage of
course is back old man cage uh Jack
himself forgot about that I don't know
if he's been confirmed he has apparently
they've only shown him as like the his
like possessed form he's not he's not in
character select right now there's like
seven slots left he's definitely in the
story though yeah uh Kano yep coming
back m
keni not confirmed yet in the story oh
really okay uh katana's back yep uh I'm
guessing million is too yeah million is
too y uh cuddle K's a new one right he's
that like kind of voodoo dude or like
God thing yeah I don't know his
background necessarily follows the but
uh yeah toal con is new Kung Jin new
character yes descendant of kung kungla
it's just Mortal Kombat babies this yeah
that's what it's about it's about the
children it's like the next generation
is it the Babalities from Mortal Kombat
2 not maybe maybe no it all comes full
circle hey maybe um are they do they
have Babalities I haven't seen anything
like that animalities they haven't
talked about friendships I'm sure they
if they're really going to stick to this
whole like you have to discover what's
in the game yeah I'm sure there would be
I'm not I wouldn't be surprised if there
is another ality DLC DLC DLC uh Kong Lao
is back yes uh liuk Kang they only
confirmed last week yes which always
seemed dumb to me because he's kind of
like the Ryu of Mortal Kombat but
apparently some people think he
shouldn't be in the game because I guess
like based on the story he is he might
be dead oh Bas oh based on the story
yeah the Mortal Kombat L you got to keep
can like Jade is dead Jade is dead and
she's not in the game she's like
katana's kind of got a variation like
Jade to bring back G
Jade important I wrote up like a little
thing based on the first chapter of this
game and I was like there's some thing I
don't understand people were like oh my
God how do you have a job and you don't
know that this x event happened at the
end of Mortal Kombat
9 oh my God good question how does he
that's Wonder not sure I'm glad L K's in
it cuz otherwise like how he's the only
person in video games who can go like
still got it got he still got the B he
still got it he still got it working out
at the gym uh quani is back yep uh
Ryden just keep going just keep going
just going reptile everyone's favorite
uh um variation on the color of the
Ninjas is he amphibian this time
remember that time they had reptile just
be a dude what is ampian like that's a
real thing he just looks more like a
lizard fr he was just wearing his ninja
ship but then when he pulled off his
mask he was like it's like a actual
reptile yeah I know that yeah but then
in another one he was like a dud like a
dude like I'm just a dude Parts no not
really yeah yeah he he just yeah he just
looked like a ninja like like their
typical ninja but he was green every
totally not a reptile reptile I'm a dude
now I just go by reptile just keep going
just keep going oh god um Scorpion's
back of course has to be yeah
shinook is back is that some sort of
helicopter no he's one of the bad guys
he's he's kind of got that uh he's the
bad guy really
yeah yeah I guess so yeah you're
probably right that's people told me in
my article anyway is him or
Molina in the story trailer kind of
seems like the person you're after but
who knows Johnny Cage and Scorpion as
Sonia blades back oh is she back is she
playable yes okay Subzero yep teada
teshi teada teshi teada hopefully I'm
saying that right never heard of
and then we also have Tanya and Tremor
which are T DLC as well are those two
separate characters Tanya's friends with
Jackie they went to the same high
schoolers yeah uh so that's Moral Kombat
X um that's all you need to know about
World Combat X da and DED you excited
for us you've been watching streams for
like weeks now yeah I mean like I I like
Peter and more of a traditional Street
Fighter person like if MK didn't have a
block button I I think I would like it
10 times more but it's harder for me to
coming from a street fighter background
like I'm used to holding back so having
like a block button it makes it it's
like another it's like another thought
process right and like especially like
Mortal Kombat 3 when they added run I
was like well [__] I'm screwed cuz I
played pad back then so it's just like
this is making it way worse but I mean
like the game looks good um I think the
fatalities are cool like even though
maybe they're not needed in Peter's
opinion but I think they're
cool that's right I called it they're
I'm glad they're there I just don't care
so much I think they're cool um and yeah
it looks clean it looks it looks like he
said faster the combos you know they're
longer so um we'll see cool yeah April
14th 2015 s in a couple of weeks time so
it won't be too long until we all get to
play Mortal Kombat X ourselves GNA give
it to you X GNA give it to you damn
it next on Pimp My Ride H we'll be back
in a second folks with a uh some chatter
about Rainbow 6 uh Siege which which
Chris played oh yeah uh which Aaron
Samson played I'm all hyped for that who
Mary is currently screaming running
through the office trying to bans
summoning him um that G's pretty rad uh
We've also got an MLB giveaway we're
going to be talking about later on the
show um but yeah might as well just put
it out there right now
gamespot.com win mlb1 15 if you want to
win MLB 15 H go in there it's all PS4
PS3 and V you just need to fill in the
sweep Stakes on there and then CH what
platform you want to win it on as well
do you have a chance of winning the
latest baseball video game did they make
more than one baseball game anymore I
think there's like an RBI game that's
coming out oh yeah I saw that an RBI
Baseball game coming
out at the same time right is that the
game I 11 better be on that what RBI
runs batter runs bed in runs bed in so
like if you're on second base and I hit
the ball and it's not a home run but you
run in after that hit yeah it's that's a
run B in RBI as RBI though you don't get
an RBI for hitting the Home Run RBI I
thought RBI was like like a really
famous baseball player like Tiger Wood
like orbi
Bobby that's not a yeah Rob vanam Rob
vanam baseball one of a kind would be
[__] way better just saying and sorry
I'm MLB the Show 15 go win it right now
uh stick around there we're back in a
second with Rainbow Six Siege uh but for
now we're going to get a trailer for
Assassin's Creed Chronicles cuz right no
not enough Assassin's Creed games out
there let's make another one
go until you have experience The Thirst
for
vengeance you cannot know the rage it
fueled until you have found a Cause
worth fighting
for you cannot know what you will
sacrifice for
it
until you have been
disgraced you cannot know the fire that
burns for
Redemption
like to make a formal apology to all of
the DMX fans out
there for what I've done so I'm so sorry
your great shame is revealed although I
also am it and then so I too apologize
yeah say I have no comment do you have
something nothing to say about this I
have nothing to say on the DMX or any X
of any type I was sure you like to
apologize for your college Years of
taking hella exstasy
blasting DMX you don't know about that I
don't you I'm will you not show us your
Rough Riders
tattoo mistakes were made my parents
don't know about that either all right
godamn it let us never speak of it that
Assassin's Creed thing look weird oh you
know yeah they like they making a 2d uh
Assassin's Creed they made them before
there was a d DS Nintendo DS Assassin's
Creed that was kind of like that yeah I
don't know 2DS I don't know kind of look
like shank or something yeah kind of
look like Prince Persia which Assassin's
Creed sort of took and now it's coming
full circle full circle Jordan mechner
is actually making this um this
Assassin's Creed 2D all it's old is new
again exactly eventually all right hey
Aaron Samson's here what iron Samson did
last week iron Samson we went to
Montreal and it was like 20° fah people
in Montreal were so happy they like it's
so warm
outside getting my raise they were like
running with babies and strollers and
like wow they were just psyched that it
was 20° Fahrenheit I have two questions
to ask you one did you have
poutine oh no I did not okay two how is
Rainbow Six Siege because you played
that video game we did it was so cold
like my brain was just kind of Frozen no
we did see Rainbow Six Siege it was a it
was like Red Faction meets Rainbow Six
so all I've seen in the trailers is is
it's kind of seems a bit like counter-
strike it's uh folks inside of a house
and then a bunch of people that's one
team and then the outside team has to
come in and get them but then it's like
it's almost like like you said Red
Faction or bad company or where you're
just just walls don't mean [__] in this
game dude it was it was really cool it
was the kind of Destruction that I've
been waiting a long time for um I mean
like literally you know I mentioned Red
Faction but like there's literally a
dude named Sledge with a sledgehammer
you can Sledge his way through walls but
he can't bust apart an entire airplane
with it in a Red Faction style there are
certain areas that you can bust through
certain that you can't some that you can
bust through but only see through and
not actually Traverse through like like
floors and ceilings you can break
through but there are only certain
points that like a trap door will form
other times as you're looking through
floorboards so what the destruction he's
referencing is like yeah right in Bad
Company 2 it was common practice to like
you see a dude in the window you just
blow out the whole wall but this is a on
a much more micro level the kind of
Destruction they're going for to the
point of like here's the barricade I'm
going to melee out half of this board
and poke my gun through it to shoot
dudes who are coming down the way yeah a
lot of people are going to learn the
difference between cover and concealment
the hard way so most of the stuff in
this game is concealment meaning people
can shoot through it yes it's not cover
like You're vulnerable anywhere in the
house practically like one of the one of
the gadgets on the defensive side dude
named pulse has a heart rate monitor he
can look up and see you a floor above
him and then just unload on the ceiling
and you'll be walking around suddenly
like rounds will start coming through
the floor and your team will be freaking
out you don't know where it's coming
from everybody will kind of like back
off he doesn't really kill anybody but
he messes up your game like kind of
breaks your confidence a little bit and
then your team has to R strategize maybe
figure out how you're going to get down
to theost even if you don't even if it's
not him you can shoot through the floor
and the team above like thinks that
maybe they're spotted or but it's maybe
just someone running around downstairs
being like just I'm just messing with
you guys like the mental game and sort
of these faints and psych outs are can
be as powerful as actually the Intel
like you know that they're there there's
also like a really strong sense of
tension they've they put together
multiple mechanics so like it's 5v5 in
the initial phase you go in with your
drones and you spot the other guys and
you know who's on the field there's
going to be I think they said 20 total I
think we saw about half of them but
depending on who you spot like if it's
if it's smoke uh then you got to watch
out for like gas traps and if it's if
it's pulse you got to watch out for
getting spotted so how many different
like so you're picking specific
characters for each team then who have
how many so it's 20 you said yeah so
there's going to be 10 and they're
specific to their role so 10 attackers
and 10 Defenders you're not going to
have the heart rate monitor on offense
right just like you're not going to have
the sledgehammer on defense so uh you
know you can't just be playing the same
character like on both sides cuz the
game alternates every match is a round
of attacking a round of Defending a
round of attacking round of Defending
first to four wins oh so it's instant
death Counter-Strike style and then
you're no responds y you just start them
the match all over that's incredible
that it's back and forth instead of
being like we'll do two and two and then
maybe swap it around for the fifth if if
there ends up being one and it's good
because we were watching the Ubisoft
stream yesterday and the defend ERS were
winning the majority of the time like to
their defense was strong the attackers
really I feel like it the attackers rely
a lot more on uh specifically
coordinated plans as opposed to sort of
reactive defending or maybe one person
holding a checkpoint or what have you uh
but because you're playing Attack you're
playing defend you're playing Attack
you're playing defend the game was
actually they were very very close in
wins right um yeah so that's it's sort
of interesting to see how it's going to
play out because we asked them when we
were there how many times does this
hostage actually get rescued you know
what are the numbers like usually just
end up killing everyone on the other
team in the entire day that we were
there I think we saw the hostage get
rescued about three times okay um was it
always a lady no it was a guy I think
most of the time okay the hostage is
actually think it was only a guy oh
really
yeah is just a McGuffin though they
should just funy style were it's
sometimes a girl sometimes a guy and
sometimes a cute dog dog you can pick
the hostage up and throw them so that's
kind of
I'm not sure that that is actually true
if that was just like some weird cuz we
played the closed Alpha version of it
and so it's not a complete I don't know
there there was a flying hostage keep it
in keep it in youself yeah how long are
the rounds then like couple I think it's
like uh it was like three minutes total
it's in the build yeah you had 45
seconds to choose your character and
choose your spawn point as a team then
you have 30 seconds uh to as the
attackers roll your little drones around
and see everything and as The Defenders
uh board things up and then the
attackers spawn and it's 3 minutes okay
three minutes the attackers do so if the
Defenders survive they yep if the
Defenders survive and the hostage is not
taken then the attacker CU and you'll
see a lot of times as time is ticking
down like three minutes doesn't sound
all that short I guess in terms of a
round of a of a shooter where like a few
bullets is going to kill you but it's
like if you're if you're in a boxing
fight it like just goes like that but
also yeah you're trying to move
cautiously and go like lean around your
Corners you can burn time so easily or
you know the like uh all right who who's
going to go up the front uh should we
send some people around the back like if
you don't have your you're on point you
can easily like get down to the wire
it's kind of like what they're trying to
do is is make it like a real Siege where
like if you're going to go in and get
the guys like unlike CS where you end up
having like one on each team just
running around the map looking for each
other on Italy like in this it's like
you need to go in and like get them all
real quick this is also where the
operator system comes into place so like
for what you know Chris and I walked up
to the door in the air airplane and like
put a breaching charge down Chris put
another breaching charge down we're like
all right double breach go you know
click it and nothing happens well mute
who's on the defending team was sitting
on the other side with like a Jammer
that that stops IT from exploding right
so now you're your plan screwed you got
balls yeah sing there oh you can put it
down it's you set it down and then go
away you don't have to be like standing
there like cranking your jam like oh God
but you know now you've just lost 20
seconds with this whole plan just came
up with that's a good chunk out of your
3 minutes that mute just like screwed up
so now you go to plan B like ash fires a
launcher into it and like blows it up
and you go from there so it's that's
right that clock management that that
like strategy back and forth uh you know
and obviously like communication is
super important and so that's something
that they talked about like figuring out
because obviously the ideal is
everyone's on chat we're all talking
cool but you can't count on players to
want to do that so they're talking about
s they didn't talk talk about the
systems that they're putting in place to
sort of put communication in there in a
non-vocal way but it's going to happen I
think like if if anything in the past 12
months has reminded us of like making a
multiplayer shooter like trying to get
people to like Pony up and spend like 50
$60 on a game with Titanfall and most
recently would evolve it can be
difficult and what what people tend to
criticize is like content a lot like
what are the things I can do so like
apart from this core game mode have they
alluded to like any other stuff that's
going to be going on in this yeah so at
E3 last year they said that there was
going to be a single player campaign or
mode uh it was unclear if it was going
to be like more cinematic or how they
were going to structure it yeah cuz it
could be more like old Rainbow Six or
like even towards Vegas maybe or it
could be just so they said they were
going to pull supposedly pull terrorist
hunt from Vegas which I is is very
requested it's like a co-op map play
through yeah I think they have conf they
confirm single player and Co-op but not
specifically what those will be or what
form they'll be but that's actually
something a lot of people were asking
about in the comments on our stuff is
like is this multiplayer only yeah cuz
it is it is tough you know for a lot of
people and how did it feel because this
is a like it's been a while since
Ubisoft have dipped back into Rainbow
Six like Vegas 2 is was that 2009 or
eight or something so does it feel good
like because I imagine this is the first
time a bunch of these Ubisoft folk have
like gone back into the first person
shooter uh World obviously it's an alpha
so it's pretty early but like head
headed a f to you guys all of the
mechanics I thought were there uh again
like building that sense of tension with
the the timer and the like player vers
player countdowns and all that that was
all there the weapons feel pretty like
standard it didn't really bother me much
just because the gameplay was so good um
but yeah I mean like it's pretty
standard Ubisoft shooting I'd say yeah
you wouldn't go in there and be like man
this FAS feels great like it's it you
can get a feel for what kind of gun it
is and what kind of like caliber power
it has but I wouldn't say any of them
were like fun to shoot but then again it
is the alpha so that being said the
explosion
were pretty crazy because when on the
defending team the the outside of
wherever you were would be breached and
then you would hear these rolling series
of explosions getting closer and closer
and closer to your room God and then you
know and then all of a sudden a wall
blows out and that sense of like just
that's dop or a ceiling or all there's
bullets coming through a wall like and
the explosion isn't just like boom
there's a hole it's like boom there's
debris scattered around the room there's
smoke in the air like that it that kind
of hangs there there's like stuff
fluttering around like it can be the
visual aspect this audio aspect of this
sort of mental game is is really cool
that's excellent and presumably just a
bunch of people firing into the dust
yeah yeah yeah all right that sounds
pretty cool have they alluded to
anything to do with like Alphas or betas
or when is it coming out like is it is
it sometime this year or it's currently
scheduled for fall of this year so but
that's kind of one of those release
dates that H who knows they are uh they
have a beta announced that you can get
into for sure by pre-ordering but no
idea when that's going to be the closed
Alpha version that we played and that
they showed on their stream it's they're
they're going to be announcing the dates
for the closed Alpha very very soon and
I think they're aiming to have it pretty
soon oh great uh and we may have some
codes to give away for that depending on
what comes our way uh but yeah excellent
yeah that would be cool if we could get
the play up before 4 E3 that would be
that'll be super brilliant uh thank you
very much gentlemen for coming on
talking about Rainbow Six Siege um I do
you guys play those old games uh Vegas I
played the whole Vegas series I play the
old ones the sick like tiger scrip
orange gamma like all the the funny
stuff they put in there you ever play of
the old like I remember getting Rogue
spear for Christmas one year I remember
playing a few rounds on the PC with just
like mapping point to point on the and
what like I feel like I'm confusing with
some other tactical shooter but uh ding
Chavez every everyone apparently he's in
like every Tom clany like thing I think
he's in like the sum of all fears as
well or something yeah he was like the
guy you wanted to keep alive the whole
way he still remember that haircut yeah
I played them back in the day but I
didn't play much Vegas I went back and
played a lot of Swat 4 oh you did
recently recently that game was way more
excellent than I remembered is it still
hold up it does it really does it's so
weird like even little details of that
game hold up there is it like you're
like cable talking people yeah you're
like cable tying masing people you throw
you throw like stun grenades and all the
balls come out like there was stuff that
was way ahead of its time in that game
yeah that came like 2003 or something or
yeah it's impossible how did you get
that cuz it's impossible to get that
digitally we had a copy like our archive
in our WOW office when I was over with
um uh The Witcher guys last week you
know gog.com good old games that's based
there as well and I like saying just get
swad four one game nobody has it I think
it's like stuck between like four
different IP holders nobody really
knows game was way better than I
remembered yeah that was like a that was
Ken LaVine that was a a rational game I
think when they pulled that off that's
pretty good pre- Rock game Swat 4 coming
soon they should make they should make a
new SWAT game should make SWAT maybe
Rainbow Six SWAT reboot I mean this is
pretty swatty I think FBI SWAT is one of
the like counterterrorist units they
have in there yeah you got uh FBI uh SAS
from England the G from France SPN
Russia just like Russia and then there's
there's like a German one that's it
begins with yeah they also have the
recruit he's like generic mcdude oh yeah
so yeah there's like the specific
operators that we were talking about but
then you can choose to just be like
recruit and you get you get like
citizens
arrest Noob like you know every load out
has a primary secondary and like a
grenade or something he gets two
grenades and can swap his primary for a
like a riot shield which is pretty rad
which is actually like really good
come through a hole with that thing like
you can actually get off some shots but
it also makes sense to with r Shield
you're like he recruit why don't you go
in that door by
yourself Shield buddy just get behind
that you'll be
fine watch your shins before we wrap it
up what else are you guys playing uh at
the moment or what are you working on at
the moment Aaron I'm still sticking with
bfield Hardline cool I'm at the point
now where I want more content for it
already it feels like it needs another
four Maps I'm still cool with the core
gamep play I'm hitting that point in
Battlefield where I'm like yeah Battle
Log it's still aggravating when is the
first DLC coming out I don't know yet
walls away do you have you been
spreading your multiplayer round from
mode to mode or do you tend to favor one
I favor Hotwire I just think it's kind
of their coolest most fun mode and you
also make insane amounts of cash oh
really yeah make a ton of money in that
and then it also has just like
ridiculous vehicle moments in it that
like couch yeah driving a couch like
there's certainly that kind of
ridiculousness but then also stuff where
you're like going off jumps and like
hitting your other cars like that kind
of vehicle collision stuff uh is is like
that kind it echoes the sort of crazy
like helicopter tank batt jets flying
over like that kind of like big bigger
scale Mayhem that other Battlefield
games have had does it still feel like
people are playing out of the servers
yes I mean on p I'm playing on PS4 the
servers are still full excellent yeah uh
what are you playing tomor Chris you
were playing some bloodborne last night
right yeah I'm playing some bloodborne
I'm trying to I usually with Souls games
I like beat the first two or three
bosses and then run out of run out of
steam so uh I beat the second boss last
night and I'm trying to see if this one
sticks a little longer I I feel like
there's some things I'm doing this time
around in terms of like upgrading
weapons and spending resources and like
folks and the way that the sort of like
prevalent shortcuts are are throughout
that are uh maybe making me feel like
I'm making progress at a better clip
yeah uh than in previous Souls s Souls
games so we'll see yeah it was cool I
started playing yesterday as well and
then we stopped playing so we could go
play soccer and like immediately like
you were like giving me tips that's how
that whole game works it's like you do a
bunch like I'm [__] at this game and
somebody's like Yo dude you should do
this and then you go back and I [__] it
I went after work I went back and played
some more and like it was like like
11:30 and it's was like 1:00 and I'm
like oh man no I better stop playing I
got to midnight and I was like I had
just come back and like leveled up twice
and I was like this and I just beaten
some dudes like this would be a perfect
place to stop this would like would be
so satisfying to just end right here and
have a great night wrapped up just going
to go one more time and I like no I
didn't it actually worked out really
well I was like I'm going to go out I'm
not going to you know I'm not going to
run back with Souls if I die and leave
him there I don't care if I go back and
get him I'm just going to find something
new and I found a lantern eventually so
I just teleported back and it end up
being better W back to the hunters Dre
that g like never P
off godamn it uh all right that's a show
before we go though I want to remind you
folks MLB 15 dos show uh is available we
have a big old sweep steak and going on
the site at the moment if you go to the
link on screen now
gamespot.com win mlb1 15 enter your
details in the sweep Stakes um it's open
the random draw so uh you can best
chance of win as anyone else and then
pick what your favorite uh platform of
choice would it be PS3 PS 4 or the
PlayStation VA for a chance to win that
bad boy H thank you very much for
watching Today's show thank you
gentlemen for coming on let's go play
some more video games no thank you Chris
thank you Danny thanks man and I really
apprciate thank you thank you and thanks
to everyone in the back uh Mary Josh Dan
and Mr Tay who was front of stage today
as well H we'll be back next Tuesday
what what game's coming out next week
what game's coming in next week what
game's coming in next
week yeah I don't know either wrap it up
that was the answer that was the answer
probably yeah let's just keep playing
bloodborne for a couple of weeks GTM
World Kombat out the week after that I
think H yes thanks for hanging out uh
there is a live stream tomorrow at 2m if
you like ax on Verge um Peter Brown is
going to be playing no Lark is g to be
playing sorry Lark is going to be
playing H who managed to speedrun the
game in 1 hour 45 minutes we're g to see
if he can do it under 1:30 uh with Peter
B tomorrow so I'll be here on
gamespot.com 2 p.m. Pacific uh that's
now we're back to Daylight savings so
it'll be 10 p.m. GMT and figure out the
something for yourself H we're out of
here thanks for watching the show see
you guys next week bye X on
DMX knock knock open up the door with
the St still give it to you you to get
it on your own the knock knock open up
the door the knop St still X going give
it to you fck you to get it on your own
X going deliver to you knock knock open
up the door real with the knop St still
give it to you you to get
it